alright guys welcome to my part 4 of how
to solve a 6x6 cube at this point all of
your centers and your edge pieces should
be solved what you have essentially done
is you have reduced this 6x6 into a 3x3
so if you take a look at the diagram I
have here you have this cube here and
you have all the edges solved I have
them here in pink or purple and the
center piece here is a 4 by 4 and that
is also completely solved now the corner
pieces on any cube are always the same
no matter how big the cube gets it's
always going to have 8 corner pieces
when you reduce it you have to visualize
it as a 3x3 so looking at it if you
pretend that these lines aren't here
that connect these pieces and it's just
one piece then you could think about it
as a 3x3 so this is just the center
piece this is one edge here and the
corners again are the same so this cube
that I have here is very similar to the
cube that I have here on the left the
3x3 this is the center piece same as
this it's connected to a white piece
just like this one is the edge piece is
the same so all you have to do is to
solve this as a 3x3 all right so before
you do go on to solve the cube as a 3x3
you want to make sure that the centers
are correct red white and blue should be
in a clockwise orientation directly next
to each other opposite of red you should
have orange opposite of blue you should
have green and remember I was using the
white cube in my last three parts now
I'm using a black cube because it's a
little easier to turn so I have the
white stickers but opposite white or
black should be yellow the way that I
solve it there's a bunch of different
methods for solving a 3x3 cube the one I
use is outlined in my channel playlist
under the 3x3 tutorial and the way that
I do it I solve a bottom white Cross
then you solve the bottom white corner
pieces and then you solve the middle
edge pieces and then finally you will
solve the top layer using algorithms ok
so as you'll see here I do have a white
cross already solved
when you're solving the cube as a 3x3
you're only going to be turning the
outer layers here you don't want to turn
these because you're going to mess up
the centers and then you're going to
have to start all over so you're only
going to be turning these outer layers
okay so what you want to do is you want
to form a white cross just like I have
here I'm not going to go into too much
detail on how to solve the cube as a 3x3
up to the bottom five layers which is
equivalent to solving the bottom two
layers but I will go into how to solve
the parity errors which occur on the
last layer so once you have the white
cross you want to solve the bottom five
layers now you can either solve the
corner pieces by themselves and then
solve the middle edge pieces or if you
know how to place the corner pieces with
the middle edge pieces together you can
do that as well I have an outlined how
to do that yet but I will soon so just
to show you how to put a corner piece
down with an edge piece I have this
piece already aligned here so what I
would do this piece is already aligned
with its edge piece so all I have to do
is lift it up bring it towards me and
then bring it back down now you'll see I
have this corner piece down with this
and you do that for all four corners and
the middle edge pieces and when you do
that you will have a cube that looks
something like this as you can see the
bottom five layers of the 6x6 cube have
been completely solved and this is
equivalent to having the bottom two
layers on a 3x3 solved so what you want
to do now is to solve the last layer of
the cube this is a little bit different
than solving a 3x3 because they're our
parity errors which occur when you're
solving the last layer that does not
occur on a 3x3 or any odd layered cube
at this point you're going to have a
parity error or you're not going to have
a parity error what we want to do at
this point is to solve the top yellow
cross so if you see a single center
piece like this with one edge piece or
if you see a 3/4 cross that means you
have a parity error if you see the
regular patterns that you would see on a
3x3 which are covered in my step four
then you don't have a parity error and
you can solve the top face so what you
want to do now if you have a pattern
like this you want to hold this edge
piece all the way to the left on
and you want to perform this move that
I'm going to go over in order to solve
the 3/4 cross on top so put this yellow
piece all the way to the left and you do
this move front face clockwise top face
clockwise right face clockwise top face
counterclockwise right face
counterclockwise and front face
counterclockwise and as you'll see right
now I have a 3/4 cross as I call it
alright now that we have the 3/4 cross
on top we want to flip this piece over
so that we have a completed cross on top
in order to do that we need to use that
really long algorithm the same one that
we use in the 4x4 cube the 5x5 and we
did see it earlier when we were fixing
that edge parity so what you want to do
is you want to hold this flipped piece
directly in front on the top face and
you're going to perform this move it's
the same move that you saw earlier but
it's a little bit modified because we're
turning a different amount of layers now
okay so hold this piece in front and you
do all three right layers twice the back
face twice the up face twice three left
layers clockwise the up face twice three
right layers counterclockwise the up
face twice three right layers clockwise
the up base twice the front face twice
three right layers clockwise the front
face twice three left layers
counterclockwise the back face twice and
the three right faces twice and as
you'll see this piece has now been
flipped over and we can go on to
complete the top yellow face alright so
now that I have the yellow cross
completed I want to get the top face
completely yellow so I'm not going to
cover how to do that in this tutorial
but my step 5 of my 3x3 covers how to do
that so in this case I do have one
corner piece next to the cross I'm going
to hold that in the bottom left and I'm
going to use this algorithm to complete
the top right clockwise top clockwise
right counterclockwise top clockwise
right clockwise top
180 degrees and right counterclockwise
and as you'll see my yellow face is now
complete
alright now that we have the top yellow
face complete we want to solve the top
corner pieces this is explained in the
step six of mine 3x3 tutorial so what we
want to do is you want to look on the
top face for any two corner pieces which
have the same color on the same face
like these do now if you turn the cube
around and you only have unmatched
corners like that that's fine
hold yellow on top and white on the
bottom and perform the algorithm that
I'm going to show you once it doesn't
matter where the other faces are once
you perform that algorithm you're going
to see that you will have two corner
pieces which have the same color on the
same face it doesn't matter what this
middle piece is once you have these two
corner pieces which have the same color
on the same face you put them on the
back face and then you perform the
algorithm again to complete all of the
top corners right counterclockwise front
clockwise right counter clockwise back
twice right clockwise front counter
clockwise right face counterclockwise
back face twice and right face twice and
as you'll see all of the top corner
pieces have now been solved and as
you'll see they are not matched up so if
you want to match them up that's fine
now you'll see that they're matched up
and they are properly oriented and now
we can go on to the last step alright
now that we have the top corner pieces
solved you're going to have to check to
see whether or not you have a parity
error now as I could see I clearly have
a parity error because I have two sides
solved and two sides unsolved that never
happens on the 3x3 on a 3x3 you can have
three sides unsolved and one side solved
if you see that on your 6x6 then you can
just finish solving it with the regular
3x3 algorithm however now that we have
two sides solved and two sides unsolved
we're going to have to do another parity
algorithm in order to correct this what
this algorithm does is it switch it
switches to top edge edge groups so it's
going to switch this one with this one
now at this point you may have only two
edge groups that are switched so what
you would do is you would do the
algorithm just to switch them since I
have two edge groups which are directly
next to each other I'm going to do the
algorithm to switch these two edge
groups when I switch it the blue edge
group will be over here and the red one
will come on to this side and then I
will have three edge groups which are
unsolved so to switch these two top edge
groups I'm going to do this algorithm
top three layers twice all three right
layers twice the up face twice all three
right layers twice the right face twice
the up face twice all three right layers
twice and the three upper layers twice
and as you'll see now I have one side
solved and three sides unsolved which is
a case that happens on the normal 3x3
and I could solve it just like that now
okay so now I have one completed side
and three incomplete faces now this is a
very common case that you'll see on a
3x3 so you should know how to solve this
I'm not going to go into detail on
exactly what I'm doing but I can see
that these pieces need to go clockwise
in a clockwise direction so holding this
on the back the completed face I'm going
to do the following algorithm right
twice up right clockwise up clockwise
right counterclockwise up
counterclockwise right counterclockwise
up counterclockwise right
counterclockwise up clockwise right
counterclockwise and that has completed
the cube if you have any other problems
or if you don't know exactly what I did
you should refer to my step 7 of my 3x3
tutorial alright guys so I hope that the
part four has help you complete your
cube entirely and I would ask if you
have any questions or comments please
leave them below in the comment section
and thanks for watching